what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today yet again we
have some awesome updates about
Spider-Man 4.
the next Spider-Man film coming in the
MCU and recently it's been revealed that
Tom Holland has signed another contract
to play Spider-Man in the MCU for three
more Spider-Man films and then three
other films as well we know two of these
are going to be Avengers the Kang
Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars of
course but that last one remains to be
seen but in the meantime like I said we
have a little bit of details about what
to expect from that first movie of the
new Spider-Man trilogy Spider-Man 4. and
it does look like Sony and Marvel
Studios might be making some kind of an
announcement soon about Spider-Man 4. so
we'll go over some details we've heard
about the plot for Spider-Man 4
including Peter Parker possibly working
at The Daily Bugle and the more grounded
story to expect from Spider-Man 4 and
when to expect an official announcement
about Spider-Man 4. we'll talk about all
of that in this video but first big
thank you to kamikoto for sponsoring
today's video if you love to cook
whether that's professionally as a chef
or just simply at your home making your
own meals I promise these knives are
perfect for you kamikoto knives are made
with high quality Japanese steel using
traditional techniques each kamikoto
knife goes through a rigorous 19 step
process that takes several years from
start to finish to complete each knife
is individually inspected before it gets
shipped out and comes with a lifetime
guarantee and the knives come in a heavy
duty Ash wood box which makes it a great
present especially with Christmas and
the holidays coming up the first time I
ever used a kamikoto knife I was
seriously impressed while cutting food I
didn't really have to push the knife
through my food rather it just kind of
glided through it giving it a perfect
cut and the reason is the kamikoto
knives use single bevel etch which means
kamikoto knives can achieve an
unbelievably sharp edge you just can't
get with other knives kamikoto only uses
steel sourced from Mills in Japan and
each blade is crafted using techniques
that have been honed and perfected by
generations of knivesmiths for over 800
years in fact kamikoto knives are used
by Michelin star chefs from all over the
world and right now kamikoto is running
a massive Black Friday sale and is
offering my viewers an extra 50 US
dollars off of any purchase with the
discount code Cosmic Wonder so you can
go to kamikoto.com thecosmic wonder
right now to get these amazing knives
and help support the channel
so right now it's pretty much been
figured out that the release date for
Spider-Man 4 with Tom Holland in the MCU
not to be mistaken with a possible Toby
Maguire Spider-Man 4 is going to be July
12th of
2024. that's a little bit over a year
and a half away and that's really good
news because one we don't have to wait
so long for the next Spider-Man film but
two that means everything with
production has to start relatively soon
for this movie which means a lot of
information about this film will come
out relatively soon most fans know how
it is when pre-production begins leaks
start happening when filming starts set
photos get taken they get put out to the
public plus not to mention the studio
teases us as well Tom Holland actually
gets very involved in teasing upcoming
Spider-Man projects it's a lot of fun
and he's not spoiling things anymore so
he's really learned to have fun with it
and that all should happen relatively
soon and like I said Sony might actually
be planning something it was recently
announced by Sony that they would be
attending ccxp however as of the past
couple of days Sony has removed the fact
that they are going to be attending ccxb
from all of their social media and
websites it is still on the CC XP
website but Sony removed all of the
stuff that they posted about it this
could be because Sony is actually
planning some big announcement that they
could be doing on their own Sony does
have a history of revealing pretty big
things at ccxp specifically for
Spider-Man in the past so it does seem
like Sony is planning something either a
possible announcement at ccxp this year
which is December 1st through December
4th or perhaps they pulled out of ccxb
so they could do something hand in hand
with Marvel Studios but either way it
could be possible not saying it's for
sure but it could be possible that Sony
and Marvel Studios are planning some
sort of a Spider-Man 4 announcement in
the next couple of months and of course
I'll be sure to do an update video if I
hear anything so be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification Bell now
moving on to what we could actually be
seeing in Spider-Man 4 yesterday Paul
over at heavy spoilers a friend of the
channel released a video talking about
some things you could expect to see from
Avengers Secret Wars and Spider-Man 4.
yesterday we covered the secret Wars
part today let's cover the Spider-Man 4
part now the first thing he talks about
is something that we've been talking
about for a while on the channel and
that is the next film won't actually
feature the Venom symbiote suit despite
the last Spider-Man film teasing Venom
in the MCU Paul has heard that they are
putting this on the back burner for now
but it still could be possible that the
reason they're putting it on the back
burner is because they want to introduce
it in secret Wars because in the comics
Spider-Man originally gets the Venom
symbiote suit for the first time in
secret Wars now as far as The Story Goes
Paul does say that it is going to be
more of a grounded story more like what
we saw in Spider-Man homecoming now this
makes sense and this is actually going
to be really cool to see because Peter
Parker is now going to be in college at
the end of Spider-Man no way home we saw
him study in a GED book this is because
the whole world forgot who Peter Parker
was so Peter Parker no longer exists in
in reality which means he no longer has
a diploma which means he is no longer a
high school graduate so Peter is going
to have to take the GED so he can now
apply for colleges but considering the
fact that Peter Parker is such a genius
that he was able to use math to defeat
Doctor Strange In The Mirror Dimension I
think he'll be all right he might not
get into MIT anymore he might have to go
to maybe a community college in New York
but regardless we will see him in
college in Spider-Man 4. and oddly
enough we haven't heard much about
Zendaya or Jacob Babylon returning I
think it would be really weird if they
didn't include them in this new Trilogy
yes you could in that story with the two
of them at the end of Spider-Man no way
home where Peter Parker decides that he
truly has to let them go for their own
safety after all the two of them are
going to MIT which is in Massachusetts
not that it's that far from New York but
this could be an opportunity to
introduce new characters to the MCU like
Gwen Stacy also Miles Morales could be
making his way to the MCU to take the
place of Peter Parker Spider-Man after
he is gone if MJ and Ned don't return
and even if they do return it's still a
great opportunity to introduce these new
characters now as far as the villain is
concerned Paul thinks we might Circle
back to scorpion finally having that
Spider-Man post-credits scene that
teased scorpion pay off now of course we
know at this point that Sony kind of
Blends their Spider-Man universes
together and that might not ever pay off
but they could simply never use him or
use him as a part of their Sony
Spider-Man universe but considering the
fact that this movie is supposed to be
more grounded having scorpion as a
villain would make sense now speaking of
it being more grounded Peter Parker is
going to have to find a job he no longer
has the help of pretty much anybody
remember nobody knows who Peter Parker
is but they still remember Spider-Man
remember at the end of no way home JJJ
is still thinking that Spider-Man is a
menace however he doesn't know now that
Peter Parker is Spider-Man nobody does
so this could lead us to a classic
Spider-Man storyline of Peter Parker
working at The Daily Bugle taking
pictures of spider man slash himself
this is something that we haven't had in
the MCU yet that is very classic
Spider-Man and I personally would love
to see it now it makes perfect sense for
them to go this story route plus also
they could then introduce Eddie Brock
and this could then set up the fifth
Spider-Man film to introduce the Venom
symbiote since Peter Parker is most
likely going to get the Venom symbiote
during Secret Wars which will take place
between Spider-Man 4 and 5. so we could
get a tease for Eddie Brock and
Spider-Man for him working at The Daily
Bugle then in Avengers Secret Wars Peter
gets the Venom symbiote suit uses it to
help defeat Kang or Doctor Doom or
whoever is going to be the main big bad
then in Spider-Man 5 he gets rid of the
suit the suit hates him then finds Eddie
Brock and then we get a classic Venom vs
Spider-Man storyline not like the story
that they're doing in the Sony
Spider-Man universe right now and on top
of all of this they are definitely going
to be building up the street level
Avengers team and since it's rumored
that Tom Holland just signed on for six
more movies and we only know five of
them them that could be the sixth movie
in this contract we get Spider-Man 4
then we get the King Dynasty Avengers
Secret Wars Spider-Man 5 Spider-Man 6
and then a street level Avengers team up
film it's been rumored that moving
forward Spider-Man is going to deal with
some of the events that will happen
during the Daredevil series I'm assuming
this is Kingpin who of course is a
classic Spider-Man villain so I'm
assuming at some point in time since
Marvel Studios knows we want this
Daredevil and Spider-Man will team up
most likely with other street level
heroes like She-Hulk and maybe some of
the other Defenders as well and this big
team up could be the last time that we
see Tom Holland Spider-Man in the MCU
and if that is true hopefully he does
pass the mantle down to somebody like
Miles Morales and so far that's
basically what we know about Spider-Man
4. and if this is what to expect from
Spider-Man 4 and the rest of the
Spider-Man films moving forward I gotta
tell you I'm really excited but hey let
me know what you think about this in the
comments down below please don't forget
to give the video a like And subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest Spider-Man news for live updates
you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf wolf